damn right I got it got it damn right to
Katikati damn right to get a job at damn
rise again hey damn right to get it got
it damn right I got it got it damn right
I got it got it damn right to get it
anyways why why my legs watch plane
landed Wi-Fi and Prince Abboud they
played lady lady watch change yeah like
a tity boi what's good man what's Hannah
was having time to be here you know
trying to UM blow a few dollars and
enjoy myself at the same time you feel
me I'm not mad at that now you know
you've had the craziest year dude
because I remember when I first started
seeing the name to change pop up I kept
saying the hell is to chain like this
dude is on everything like and then I
you know find out that it you know it
was tity boi you change your name um
about what time like what's the time
frame you know when you decided to to
you know switch up the name and switch
up the I guess the hustle man you just
been on the solo grind heavy right right
now man well it definitely wasn't an
overnight process as far as my grind to
my hustle man as far as the name changed
you know it's nothing that i sat on the
plant it was something that was always
in my material was always in my flow of
my reps I think as of lately I just
started catching the attentions of a few
and I start delivering and saying it
before my versus just called the kitchen
of may be made it you know maybe more
kid friendly and maybe more lady
friendly you feel me so I you know have
any complaints I definitely gain more
fans over the last two years and I'm
appreciative of the whole process you
know I mean it's been a ground like i
said i have a new mixtape about new car
true religion yeah it's doing very well
in line you know over 800,000 views and
300,000 downloads so that's a blessed
man great features on there so i said
i'm just a prodigal hard-working film
yeah most definitely um of course you're
independent still correct yes I um I
gotta imagine that you did
calls from everyone right now trying to
sign you um Mac Miller just sold 100 you
know forty nine thousand units
independently no they first week first
week he's number one out in the country
brute yeah I was well I was going to ask
you I guess you didn't know about that
but I mean what is um what is it going
to take for two chains of like sign are
you going to keep it in d i'll probably
do some others I'm gonna stop saying it
because I you know but for the most part
it has to be the right deal has to feel
right it has to have a lot of um you
know something to do with progression is
because as of right now I'm doing a lot
so I have to see know what their plans
are from me you know for the future and
things of that nature but no for the
most part you know tonight in Vegas this
will be our clothes I think I want 730
knife show this year so we're grinding
it out you know and we just had that
kind of mentality where we just gonna
take our time you know I mean it's been
you know we've been doing it for a while
so I just feel like I campaign is moving
further to the west know you know you
know you know and it's just a good
opportunity for me at my campaign you
knowing at the time comes before the
years are too may be incurred deal I'm a
entertainment but I'm not I'm not just
you know is there anybody like you can
speak on this test that you might be
talked to numb my god everybody
everybody everybody everybody everybody
and they know they are there it is like
you say you kind of like it's been like
a campaign man like you know you drop
the coating Cowboys we blew up spinning
out radio play with no label the true
religion tape is you know is everywhere
maze every day song with jade is crazy
about this Thank You food yeah a lot of
joint but um what did you have like a
did you sit down with your camping like
did you guys come up with like a
marketing plan for like how are you how
you guys were going to like you know go
from here to where you are now or did it
just kind of happened organically it was
organically and we also have a planet
you know knowing I have a lot of
concepts for the things that I do and I
just try to capitalize off this
opportunity to pay to put out music and
the capture people's ear so what makes
taste maybe a little bit more different
than someone else to swim we use their
mixtape it may be offensive throw away
songs
right now samples that couldn't get
clean I really make like album type of
material and and I capitalized on my
lifestyle whether it be talking about
loud out the whole you know lean
campaign whatever it is everything is
just it's just I just not a cover to
live off of it and make it work for me
and I mean and therefore month my tastes
a different i do photo shoots i do
videos you know i mean i can entries
documentary DVDs and they're so no I
mean I just feel like mixed take some
more accessible than real albums you
know I mean I put our to relapse with
playoff circle and the dtp NW and I just
felt like they were maybe under ship due
to the fact that they're not a lot of
places to buy physical CDs you know
acceptor and so rather be until it is
that their record stores are dying yeah
so with it being so digital would make
sense you can put them anywhere i'm
gonna roll it a lot you can put them in
truck stops clothing stores things of
that nature so i kept alive out there
most definitely um like you said this is
your would you say like hundred and
thirty-nine show or something like that
this year um are you seeing more money
as solo artists independently then you
were being assigned to Def Jam I mean it
seems like you're I mean play a circle
you know you guys have had to hit record
were weighing on and but it seems like
your ruffle bag boy seated you know all
all previous you know successes man up
to this point yeah I mean you know
definitely more more money but there's
more money but it's more money spent as
well you know not going to la by myself
like myself yeah it's different when you
have a machine helping you get to get
you know a little profit but with me I
you know I invest a lot in to myself so
for a lot of the profit I just you know
kind of recycled it into another part of
the marketing or another part of the
music you know that's what I do in that
side continue to stay high that's what
my record is still doing well at radio
and just reaching market isn't this week
you know I mean
help you know so I just keep it going
like that and it's because of me it's a
sacrifice but somebody has to do you
know yeah yeah mad at that man that's
where it is on playing circle are so
y'all just dropped a new video was it
last week did that in the hood one day
rocking around you know this car role
model so you know it was just a no-show
we still cooling at kicking the we
understood yo together my boy dollar
just drop the home his mixtape called
controlled substance so we're working on
now and for the duffel bag boys and just
trying to open up some more doors to
feed some families if d is the group
still signed the DGP as a week i was the
other thing we're trying to figure out
it up for the league legality part you
know me right you know that was an
element but you're popping like on some
other stuff that literally I know
correct your exam by here well you know
it's just you know this time you know I
mean I kind of how I definitely learned
a lot that's like my brother and I also
an are you know his new project I
actually gave him a few beats on the new
mixtape you do know I they feature yeah
I want to make take this dope you know
but I actually gave him some beats for
like I was a future you know that's me
actually gave him a couple tricks up
over this way you know me so he working
a little person which is really awesome
other you know other level type of stuff
so you kind of like me in on some
business stuff nobody checking my pocket
which is cool you know Sam from the
other angle just me having a a new
mentor and just trying to have my own
imprint you know I kind of boss count of
nature I am I just trying to take it
better that where I got hot and created
you know independent definitely now you
got to chew that you make safe which you
know if you could do so much off that
makes a person so many bangers on that
tape own but are you going to work on
another mixtape are you working on an
album you're going to wait for a deal to
work on an album what's up with that I'm
Philip them of them about everything you
can do as far as mixed times you know I
don't wanna play it up play yourself
like i like i like the fact that i went
trending the day i drop within 30
minutes i like to fake the night messed
up a server whole lot mixed taste for
about seven
I was trying to download I like that
just person I like it he had a big deal
so for me I felt like I did I felt like
I I've done so much of my previous work
as far as codeine cowboy Evans came on
februari shopping buddy too much came
out the previous October and then you
know of course we got true doesn't it
just dropped November first I felt like
I've done everything except really go
overseas that's what I'm trying to do
this tight really take my go in there's
nowhere to get my passport stuff yeah
man off the stuff that I'm doing so if I
do that I feel like I've conquered you
know basically everything you can do
with a mixtape and of course I will be
looking forward to working on my first
solo album which would be crazy I'm sure
yeah I mean you are on everything right
now man it's like I mean feature wise
you are on everything um I saw the other
day you it takes a picture with you and
meth talk about your big blue tank ran
home then coming out the sounds like is
it are there are some influences like
some I guess what people would call real
hip hop influences of East Coast hip hop
influences that that people might be
surprised by it oh yeah deficit you know
at the end of the day a lot of buzz
coming from where we came from we like
to help some with some stuff a substance
right narrative yeah so it was always
and that's why you see our music being
aware it is too will be combined you
know substance and lives to a heartbeat
because for the most part you know they
thought we just had dance music you know
they thought we just brought you know
what they call shaky booty music that I
like the same until we have maybe
outcast and goodie mob so for us coming
up it was easy to understand myself
further over the top over the head maybe
metaphor I get it like that before us to
get out with someone like a rake horn I
Ghostface who kind of talked about their
version of their trap right and how they
dealt and knowing things that I nations
is kind of related to it maybe Jay Z and
a few other cats from pop-top that
hustle you know I mean they came from
the block and that's why you know we
kind of like you know especially for me
like rocking with Jadakiss thousand
since I felt like that was a huge
for me to better reach on him do it and
that was a big deal for men you know I
made him being like a legend for the
East Coast just a few other kids you
know they came up i had that word but
you know yeah most definitely man way to
change going down tonight vegas trip
hotshot sodomie Raven to change you go
make it rain tonight from Atlanta min
haha sure the hose got to be happy
someone from a task on the strip club
tonight he will soon go to a party
tonight when I heard I got an early
flight so I think I mom there's a
thoroughbred that works trip hop oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah there are some
thoroughbreds way further than I
midnight tonight million extendo you
know hahaha you know the campaign that
for bad boys to gunk and we cool it feel
good you know to be out here in Vegas
man no bright lights you know there it
is ayo before I let you go with what
some like I said you're on everything
right now man was late with some
features that you are working on or got
hit up about that we could expect many
more I more so much stuff more like
really it's like hell even know why I do
it i gotta i have a bunch of futures
done i think i'm going to be on telling
us I think but I know it probably I'm
but up no my boyo Machine Gun Kelly it a
while yeah yeah he'll be looking out for
the um I gotta do have done yet but
thinkers of my email a wild boys remix
and then be looking out for the wall a
joint debate that debate remakes I was
supposed to do a verse for that and then
well just trying to visually look at my
email in my head because I about selling
features I supposed to but um gotta do
one for my boy oh jae millz you know
young money of course already did my
tried to tighten feature shock to him
Gary um and I'm really stove right now
before I have a lot of things I know
which is a good thing look how I feel
looking up for the e-40 i'm john i did
for him and then you know if she gonna
video out probably oakland with pressure
for the song that someone make stay with
her so be looking out for that as well
I've been in the lab and a lot of stuff
shall i come now the Freddie Gibbs club
all you did on his take yeah already got
about that as well yeah shots in Helmand
his company home I like I kicking until
you knock me down with geez you'd be
looking out for that I'm or Jeezy I'm
just coming up they did a John him cause
super freak that's pretty hard that's on
album yes on the album that's what I
long yeah i made about five albums this
year I mean the DJ drummer I made the my
boy Johnny but I made the arm I made the
Lloyd album I made them gucci mane and
Waka have them I've gotta go 12 let's
without my husband's oh hell no you bout
to drop of how am I got someone that's
what it is man well sometimes we
appreciate you coming through man a
reuleaux respect like it's crazy to see
um you know independent music winning
again and it's dope it's a dope thing to
see just the way you you know you've
done it the last year managed to say
this is pretty nice sort of an
incredible homie self respect me alright
man appreciates up yes sir